scientists are puzzled by a very
disturbing trend in the waters along
four Gulf Coast states almost 300 dead
and dying dolphins think about that for
a second have washed ashore since
February and that's about three times
the usual number mark Strassmann went
out on the water with researchers
working very quickly to save the
remaining animals he's in Clearwater
Beach Florida near Tampa Bay so mark
what do we know so far well Gail hey
good morning here's what we do know
scientists can't stop whatever's
happening no one can out there but they
are aggressively trying to get to the
bottom of whatever it is off the coast
of st. Petersburg Aaron fujairah with
NOAA Fisheries took us out on their
dolphin research vessel we found this
pod of eight or nine dolphins all
healthy swimming a half mile from shore
they do but from Louisiana to the
Florida Panhandle coastline residents
keep seeing a dolphin die-off they're
all bottlenose dolphins which live
closest to shore
many were adults the single day record
is nine so this is the texas-louisiana
border last week NOAA's marine mammals
standing program which fujur oversees
designated this die-off an unusual
mortality event or ume so all of this
concerning alarming I would say it's
concerning and and and you know
bordering on alarming primarily because
it's a group of dolphins that have been
impacted because of other unusual
mortality events so this is the same
area that was impacted by the Deepwater
Horizon spill scientists are exploring
several possible causes from the
lingering effects of the BP oil spill in
2010 two skin lesions on many recovered
dolphins that indicate freshwater
exposure
heavy rainfall here has flowed from the
Mississippi into the Gulf or it could be
chemicals of pollutants or a combination
it's an area where dolphins have been
previously exposed to oil they have
compromised health they have lingering
health issues
and so they are more susceptible to any
additional stressor anything could tip
them potentially over the edge oh this
is what researchers want to see
throughout the Gulf healthy dolphins
unthreatened by a mysterious danger
lurking hundreds of miles away even if
the numbers stopped right now we still
have a long way to go so the work isn't
going to end we'll be figuring out which
tests and which analyses we need to
conduct and we're going to be looking
forward that whatever's happening there
is no known threat to people and out on
the water you could tell these
scientists really are motivated to find
out what's going on when we came across
those healthy dolphins Tony their faces
just lit up all right mark thank you
very much we're rooting for those
dolphins we are you would hate to think
that it's anything caused by humans that
is making whatever that is causing these
dolphins to come such a sad sight to see
their dolphins on the shore they'll
figure that out